question of the day what would be the
question of the day what is your
favorite color it's cuz I did this I
always liked ah good morning believe
nation today's message is question
everything over to you hi all Miyazaki
business the Tama technical tomorrow
Jesse Frank my rock on the critical to
know touch me tonight at is inductive at
all it's more than iron Stephen 16 on
TechnoMarine assignments did so know
even orders even 30,000 optimal Tita he
doesn't know
Yoshi at all into it's no fabric lesson
yesterday were automata CRM home
entertainment rejection continue across
India demo so in order to even a decoder
taka-taka-taka-taka the dictatorial
Scrivener Tiffany company it's good they
can I tell me what so what do you think
I think it's a really valuable lesson
for everyone to be reminded of I think
if you're in an older school industry if
you're if you're maybe a little deeper
into your career if it's not something
you're doing that's fresh and new
I think it's easy to fall into the trap
of just doing things the same way you
always did it cuz it's the fastest is
the cheapest it's the way the industry
does it I think if you're in a new
industry if you're in a new career if
you're starting a new business if you're
have a have a fresher mindset I wants a
younger but a fresher mindset I think
you're naturally questioning everything
I think you're turning things upside
down I think you're thinking of better
ways to do it so I think it really
depends on how deep into your career you
really are whether you're working with
this mindset or not I think it's a
really important message for
entrepreneurs I find so many
entrepreneurs get blocked as they built
their business you hit it you hit a peak
and you can't seen the bus through and a
lot of it is because when you start
you're doing something different you're
doing something
you want to change the way the industry
work and you come with those innovative
ideas and then somewhere along the line
you box yourself into a certain way of
doing it because this is what helped me
to be successful so here's what we're
gonna keep doing and you stop innovating
you stop doing new things and so you've
created this box for yourself and as
entrepreneurs we hate being in boxes and
then what happens is you start to get
bored of your business because you crave
new and exciting things that's what we
do as entrepreneurs and then you come up
with side projects and and pet things
that you want to work on and you take
your eye off the business and it's
because you have changed but your
business hasn't changed with you and
your business should always be a
reflection of who you are as an
entrepreneur and I think that I've seen
so many entrepreneurs go through this
where what you start off selling and
what makes you successful to start is
often not what you will continue to do
as you grow you have to evolve and
change and often the success of the past
become these chains that hold you where
you are that you need to break free if
you want to have real successes in
entrepreneur I think something that was
mentioned in there which was really
interesting is about doing things the
easy way and he was questioning you know
we can't do things the easy way so it's
not only whether you're doing things the
way that they've always been done or
you're trying to say I don't have
confidence in ceará so I'm going to
learn some other people how they do it
and copy it it's about not it's about
working hard enough challenging yourself
enough to do things that are maybe hard
pushing yourself out of your comfort
zone not taking the easy way out when
you have a million other things to do
and anyone else would in your situation
would give you a free pass you're gonna
hold yourself to doing something a
little bit harder working a little bit
harder and that'll take you much further
you have to be extraordinary you have to
be extraordinary if that's your one word
so the question today today is let us
know a time in your life where you
didn't take the easy way out and you're
super proud of the outcome I like it
share in the comments below we're gonna
join in the discussion thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and we'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso